The joe rogan experience.
So this weekend I'm in Philadelphia,
right?
We're there for the UFC and I'm with my boy,
Tommy Jr and his girl Katie.
And we get high as Jesus on the fucking space shuttle we got,
we got down Joe Diaz,
we went deep.
We just kept smoking.
You've got to break up the gate.
We'd,
when I come up here,
Doug,
what are you talking about?
Don't do shit to me.
If you make me drive 40 minutes up,
you've got to get me stolen bro.
That's us.
What?
Hannah weed.
I've been telling you about that shit.
Yeah,
you brought that shit to the ice house to that shit.
Don't do nothing to you and you're so crazy.
It's true.
Need to go to a doctor.
Fuck dog.
When you talk to your dog.
He had a good week dog.
Enough is enough with this Shelly.
It's the best round like Jack.
The rest you can buy.
We know it's not looking at my fucking eyes bro.
I look high to you guy
cause I smoke.
I'm away.
Cause I knew you were going to give me that slash four fucking weed.
You better start getting some good fucking,
we'd go hand in my 10 a week.
Give me a second time and a fucking rock.
Dude.
You just bang wreck and was garbage.
They sold you on it and my eyes so
relaxed.
I love you too.
I love you.
Got to go to a doctor.
Damn bad ass shit.
The fuck are you smoked and look at me.
What?
Broken?
Fucking broken.
He hit me with this.
Let's do this bro.
Motherfucker.
How high are you right now,
bro?
Fuck.
Look at him.
[inaudible] ambulance.
The biggest thing was that it was a tightly rolled joint
power hits where he's just fuels and as long as you are you like big.
No,
I couldn't get a hit off of it was too fucking tight.
Fucking screaming at America listening to no,
fuck that you're high and you give me that stuff.
You know I love you to death,
but you got to pack the 18th punked.
Joey.
Jesus fucking Christ love people who are listening to this.
You understand that this is entertainment.
I know all you're doing is complaining about not complaining.
I'm just saying that I want to get high when I'm not complaining.
Listen to what you're doing that's complaining.
You invite me to your home and you give me this sucks.
What?
Hannah weed?
I what the fuck is a saas squat?
Hannah?
What?
Uh,
what the fuck are you talking about?
US Susko Hannah hat.
No,
I haven't.
Costello is cheap.
Fucking ass.
Fucking planet.
Are you from fucking smoking?
I should've shut the fuck up.
Well,
you,
I'm talking about the Goddamn thing I did this weekend.
You were talking about that shit with you just sparked.
You are so fucked up.
Fuck.
Look at my eyes.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
It's not that you weighed 300 pounds and he smoked pot all day every day.
That's what
fucking do it.
It's not sad.
It's the physical size of your body.
Shitty.
Fucking weak or you're crazy.
Yeah.
I go to other stores.
The fuck out of you.
That's the second time on wine.
Love complaining.
Whining and complaining.
He's so Brodie.
You're so burns.
This is Joey [inaudible].
Joey,
please shut the fuck up,
man.
This is a God damn podcast.
You've been complaining for five fucking minutes about weed.
You're telling me that what slash why?
Hannah?
You know what?
That's what happens.
I don't know what Sasquatch squat.
Han Is.
No more fuck fucking late night podcast with Joe.
No more.
You can't have a dog.
I have just saying.
I love you too,
but there's 2000 people listening right now by hundreds of thousands of
listening online and all you're doing is complaining about weed for five
minutes.
Yeah,
that might have been ruined.
Really been a big fan of her youtube to shut the fuck up about this thing.
I've got to tell you about Philadelphia.
Fuck God dammit.
You try to change the subject after he beats me down.
I was just trying to calm him down for a sec.
Don't talk about we dog dot around me,
dog.
I've been talking about read.
Got No fucking Billy has it.
Has a cracked bell.
Yeah.
We're in Philadelphia.
Cheer up fucking human being.